let me uh ask you then to analyze
starship in that same way
i i know you have you'll talk about in
more detail about starship in the near
future perhaps yeah talk about it now if
you want um but just in that same way
like you said you see when you see up
when you see a rocket you see a sort of
a list of risks in that same way you
said that starship is a really hard
problem
so there's many ways i can ask this but
if you magically could solve one problem
perfectly one engineering problem
perfectly which one would it be
on sorry on starship so is it maybe
related to the efficiency the
uh the engine the weight of the
different components the complexity of
various things maybe the controls of the
the crazy thing has to do to land
no it's actually the by far the the
biggest thing absorbing my time is uh
engine production
not not the design of the engine but
i've often said prototypes are
are easy production is hard
um
so
we have the most advanced rocket engine
that's ever been designed um
the because i say currently the the best
rocket engine ever is probably the rd180
or rd170
that that's the door russian engine
basically um and um
and still i think an engine should only
count if it's gotten something to orbit
um
so our engine has not gotten anything to
orbit yet
um but it is it's the first engine
that's actually
better than than the the
russian rd engines which were amazing
design
so you're talking about raptor engine
what makes it amazing what what are the
different aspects of it that
make it like what are you the most
excited about uh if the whole thing
works
in terms of efficiency all those kinds
of things
well it's
the raptor is a
a full flow
uh staged combustion um
engine and it's at
operating at a very high chamber
pressure
so one of the key figures of merit
perhaps the key figure of merit is
um
what is the
chamber pressure at which the rocket
engine can operate that's the combustion
chamber pressure
um so a rafter is
designed to operate at 300 bar possibly
maybe higher that's 300 atmospheres so
um
the record right now for operational
engine is the rd engine that i mentioned
the russian rd which is i believe around
267
bar um
and the the the difficulty of the
chamber pressure is increases on a
non-linear basis so
10 more
pressure is
more like uh
50
more difficult
um
but that that share of pressure is that
that is what allows you to get a very
high power density
for the engine
so
enabling
a very high thrust to weight ratio
and
a very high specific impulse
so specific impulse is like a measure of
the efficiency of a rocket engine or um
it's really the the
the uh
exhaust the effective exhaust velocity
of of the gas coming out of the engine
um
so uh
with it with a very high chamber
pressure you can have um
a
a compact engine that nonetheless has a
high expansion ratio which is the ratio
between the uh
um
exit nozzle
uh and the uh
throat so you know engine's got like you
see a rocket engine's got like sort of
like about like a hourglass shape it's
like a chamber and then it next down and
there's a nozzle and the ratio of the
the exit diameter to the
the throat
expansion ratio so why is it such a hard
engine to manufacture
at scale
uh it's very complex
it's a lot of what does complexity mean
here's a lot of components involved
there's a lot of a lot of components and
a lot of
uh unique materials
that uh so we had to invent a
several alloys that don't exist in order
to make this engine work
um
materials problem too
it's a materials problem and um it is in
a staged combustion a full flow stage
combustion there there are many uh
feedback loops in the system
so
you uh
basically you've got
uh
propellant and and and uh hot gas
flowing
simultaneously to so many different
places on the engine
and
they they all have a recursive effect on
each other so you change one thing here
it has a recursive effect here it
changes something over there and and
it's
it's it's quite
hard to control
um
like there's a reason no one's made this
before um
but
um
and the reason we're doing um a stage
combustion uh
full flow
is because it it has the highest uh the
highest uh
theoretical possible uh efficiency
um
so
in in order to make a fully reusable
rocket
um
which that's the really the holy grail
of orbital rocketry um
you have to have
everything's got to be the best uh it's
got to be the best engine the best
airframe the best heat shield
extremely light uh avionics
um
very you know very clever control
mechanisms
you've got to shed mass in
any possible way that you can
for example
instead of putting landing legs on the
booster and chip we are going to catch
them with a tower
to save the weight of the landing lens
legs so that's like
i mean
we're talking about catching
the largest flying object ever made
uh
with
on a giant tower with with chopstick
arms
it's like karate kid with the fly but
much bigger
i mean pulling this probably
won't work the first time
uh anyway so this is bananas this is
banana stuff so you mentioned that you
doubt well not you doubt but there
there's days or moments when you doubt
that this is even possible
it's so difficult
the possible part is
well at this point
we'll i think we will get starship to
work
um
um there's a question of timing how long
will it take us to do this
uh how long will it take us to actually
achieve uh full and rapid reusability
um because it will take probably many
launches before we are able to have full
and rapid reusability
um
but i can say that that the physics
pencils out like the like we're not uh
like at this point i'd say we're
confident that that
like let's say
i'm very confident success is in the set
of all possible outcomes
for a while there i was not convinced
that success was in the set of possible
outcomes
so which is very important actually
but so
um
saying there's a chance i'm saying
there's a chance exactly um
uh just not sure how
how long it will take uh
we're very very talented team they're
working night and day to make it happen
um
and uh
and like like so the the critical thing
to achieve for the revolution in space
flight and for humanity to be a space
frank civilization is to have a fully
and rapidly reusable rocket oval rocket
um there's not even been any oval rocket
that's been fully reusable ever and this
has always been the
the the holy grail of rocketry um
and uh many smart people very smart
people uh have tried to do this before
and have not succeeded so
um because it's such a hard problem
you